hello devin you've talked about learning
what you've learned in the playoffs is
that it's a series that is not just one
game so
just speak to that mindset of going back
to milwaukee knowing you get that one
you'll be back here for a game seven
i mean one at a time you know our focus
is the milwaukee right now
um you know that's how you have to do
these series one game at a time and
um yeah that's it
dave here in the front look i wanted to
ask you about the play you guys are down
one you're coming down the court
you pick up your dribble around the foul
line uh and then drew comes in
um just what were you seeing on the
court in that moment and when you
kind of had a little bit of a transition
opportunity what were you seeing in
as you surveyed the court was just
trying to score the ball he was behind
me i turned and he was right there
over the right side go ahead hey devin
um
you know obviously you had a great night
but it it seemed like a lot of times
that
there was a lot of isolation there
wasn't a ton of ball movement i know you
talk about point five and then
there weren't many of those possessions
did you think things got
and maybe this for chris too that things
were just too isolated and stagnant on
offense for too long during the night
yeah the whole third quarter you know
was pretty much that
we were trading basket for basket for i
think five minutes straight
um but you know we're at our best when
we get stops and get out in transition
so
um that's we hang out always say we hang
our hat on the defensive end and that's
where we have to be better
and chris what did you think about just
kind of the ball movement and did you
feel it got a little stagnant at times
uh yeah it definitely did especially in
that second quarter when i was out there
we talk about it all season long we've
been a ball movement team and
you know sometimes the switching can
cause you to do that you know we
we exploit it at times and sometimes we
don't uh
we'll go back and look at the film and
see what we could
could have did better gina
for both you guys i mean you haven't
lost three games in a row in
six months since january and haven't
really faced a must win as far as an
elimination game situation all playoffs
so just
i know you get how much you guys pride
yourself on resilience and fighting back
so just
what do you hope to see from from you
guys and your teammates the next two
days to get ready for game six
just embrace it yeah you know
we knew this wasn't gonna be easy uh we
didn't expect it to be
and i mean it's hard you know coach said
it all year long you know everything we
want's on the other side of heart and it
don't get no harder than this
you know so we got to regroup um
learn from this game but it's over
you know we got to get ready for game
six anthony
um from your perspective what what
happened in that second quarter
and uh do you feel like that's where you
guys lost the game uh it's a 48 minute
game
you know i'll go back and look at it and
see you know but uh
you know we we got to play uh the way we
started off the game we got to put a
full game together like that especially
going there
and um we got to win a game
in milwaukee so that's all that matters
right now palmer to you on zoom
i'm gonna go to greg moore with the
arizona republic
thanks fellas um this obviously a really
tough loss devin how frustrated are you
for chris right now
next next question please
dwayne over on the right side they
obviously shot the ball from 312 was
that just a matter of them making shots
so would you feel like the defense
was it more of them or was it more with
you how you guys were defending the
three
tonight i think we gotta
you know impose our will you know i
think in that third quarter
i remember as time out and the guys said
they had missed a shot that whole
quarter
you know and uh like i said we
we come straight here from from the game
we ain't looked at nothing yet you know
what i mean so i think we'll
go home look at it watch it tomorrow and
we'll see we need to do better for game
six
chris in the back
guys there are a couple of miscues on
when the oscars is at the free throw
line
um they got the offense rebound a couple
times is that a matter of just the ball
bouncing a certain way or you think you
guys could do something differently on
those situations
i'd have to go re-look at it but you
know he is a
you know he's a freaking nature he's a
different size dude so even if he's
boxing out getting a hand on it
you know it's tough so you know you just
have to put it put a body on them
everybody's out there anticipating to
miss you know hell even he is
you know what i mean so um you know we
got to keep trying to box out and then
if his
his length you know he tipped the ball
up in the air ain't
ain't too much you can do all right
thanks guys